[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاسبوع القادم هو الاسبوع الاوحد في
السنه والذي يختص بزراعه جميع المحاصيل
شتويه كانت ام صيفيه والعامه يسمونها
ببذره الست وهي الايام السته صالحه
للزراعه كل شيء ثلاثه ايام من اخر الشبط
وثلاثه ايام من اول العقارب وعاده ما تكون
انتاجها ذات جوده عاليه خاصه القراعيات
تبدا في يوم غد الجمعه وتستمر طوال
الاسبوع القادم من يفعل الخير لا يعدم
جوازيه لا يذهب العرف بين الله والناس من
يزرع الخير يحصد ما يسر به وزارع شر منكوس
على الراسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاسباب التي تجعل هذه الايام تتسم بهذه
السمه هي ضعف المناعه الارضيه والتقلبات
الجويه خلال هذه الايام فالبذره التي لا
تقبل في اول النهار تقبل في اخره والزراعه
تنقسم الى ثلاثه اقسام زراعه صيفيه وزراعه
شتويه وزراعه مختلطه الصيفيه تكون في موسم
الربيع والشتويه تكون في موسم الخريف
والزراعه المختلطه هي الايام الست اما
الغرس فلا يكون الا في نجمه بلينا وما
تبلى النجوم الطوالع وتبقى الجبال بعدنا
والمصانع فلا جزعون ان فرق الدهر بيننا
وكل فتى يوما به الدهر فاجعوا
[موسيقى]